je voudrais évidemment revenir
sur un sujet que vous connaissez
vous avez été informé et
qu'à notamment citer votre directeur de
cabinet qui est un point important qui
est finalement la suppression d'une
subvention à une association qui est
depuis a été citée par la presse elle
n'avait pas été un audition mais c'est
SOS Racisme
et simplement vous dire qu'il y a
là-dessus plusieurs aspects qui sont
étonnants et quelquefois un peu choquant
le premier c'est que
le 25 mai a lieu le comité de sélection
le 25 mai et le 27 mai il y a un mail de
votre membre de votre cabinet
au préfet Gravel en disant j'ai soumis à
la ministre votre note on fait le point
demain
votre note c'est à dire la note
concernant le comité de sélection de la
de la veille
ou deux jours avant
et juste après vous prenez il y a une
décision qui est prise par vous selon
votre directeur de cabinet qui est de
supprimer une ligne budgétaire du comité
de sélection qui est celle concernant
SOS Racisme je crois que c'est à hauteur
de 100000 euros de mémoire et qui était
elle dans le comité de sélection donc
sur on a parlé des problématiques avant
le comité de sélection on a parlé des
problématiques durant le comité de
sélection et même après le comité de
sélection combien il y a toujours pas de
compte-rendu du comité de sélection
en réalité le comité de sélection
je ne sais pas si sélectionne on sait
plus puisque à la sortie comme vous
dites vous validez mais en fait quand
vous validez le résultat du comité de
sélection en réalité vous influez sur le
résultat vous influencer le résultat en
supprimant et et votre directeur de
cabinet a une expression particulière en
indiquant que c'est suite d'ailleurs à
des questions personnelles entre
l'expression et pas exactement celle là
mais l'esprit c'est cela
passé entre vous et l'association en
question est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire
comment les choses se passent dans cette
affaire là si Monsieur le Directeur de
Cabinet Monsieur le Préfet a eu
raison de présenter les choses ainsi
est-ce que vous dites non c'est pas le
cas enfin qu'est-ce que vous répondez à
ça
bien sûr monsieur le Président je vous
remercie de me poser la question et me
permettre justement d'apporter des
éléments de d'éclairage je répondrai à
tous les points sans exception d'abord
je vais être très clair je n'ai pas
supprimé de subventions à SOS Racisme je
dis pas que c'est ce que vous avez dit
mais j'ai vu des réponses qui ont été
portées en ce sens disant que mes
décisions auraient mis en péril un
équilibre financier d'une association je
rappelle qu'on est sur un appel à projet
on parle pas de financement ni de
fonctionnement pour les associations
donc je n'enlève pas de l'argent à SOS
racisme dont il bénéficierait chaque
année
alors je vais je vais y revenir mais en
tout cas premier élément
c'est subtil comme réponse je pense que
le droit emporte monsieur le Président
d'une part et d'autre part au-delà du
droit quand la réalité est aussi là
c'est à dire vous n'attribuez pas 100000
euros qui avait été sélectionnés
entendu très bien
[Musique]
d'être le plus
actuel possible dans la mesure où à
titre personnel je n'avais aucun
souvenir du fait qu'il y ait eu des
discussions sur SOS Racisme dans le
cadre du Fonds Marianne
maintenant qu'on a appelé ce sujet à mon
attention j'ai souvenir qu'il y a eu des
échanges sur SOS Racisme je me base sur
les faits et sur les échanges écrits que
j'ai pu trouver pour rétablir une
chronologie ce qu'on me ce que je
comprends aujourd'hui ce qu'on me dit
c'est qu'il y a une liste établie par le
comité de sélection du fond Marianne
avec des dossiers qui font l'unanimité
du comité de sélection et avec certains
qui sont entre guillemets en liste
complémentaire c'est-à-dire pour débat
je comprends de ce qu'on me dit
aujourd'hui que SOS Racisme fait partie
de cette liste complémentaire et qu'il
n'y a pas consensus au sein du comité de
sélection et qu'il y a divergences
certains considérants qui ne faut pas
attribuer cette subvention et d'autres
considérant contraire qu'il faut
attribuer cette subvention le point
m'excusant c'est pas le compte enfin
c'est pas le compte rendu que nous avons
du préfet le préfet nous dit j'ai
simplement demandé
qu'il y ait une réserve sur ce dossier
pour pouvoir vous en parler
personnellement c'est pas la même chose
que de dire qu'il y a un désaccord il y
a pas des accords il y a simplement une
précaution de vérification auprès de
vous d'un accord sur le fait qu'on voilà
je comprends bien que ce n'est pas la
même chose Monsieur le Président mais
moi c'est la version que j'ai
aujourd'hui et que je partage avec vous
aujourd'hui d'après ce qu'on me dit
d'après ce que je retrouve dans les
échanges ce qu'on vous dit Madame c'est
ce que vous savez quand même vous
oubliez pas tout de votre vie quand même
je veux dire monsieur le Président mais
en deux ans j'ai eu à présider un
certain nombre de réunions à rendre un
certain nombre d'arbitrages et surtout
je ne peux pas me souvenir de réunion
auquel je n'ai pas participé donc l'igéa
ou vous même ou peut-être même la
justice établiront ce qu'il en est moi
je porte à votre connaissance le fait
que aujourd'hui j'ai une note sur une
question de justice dans ce cas précis
on est juste sur comprendre
mais moi j'essaye de partager avec vous
les éléments que je recoupe je comprends
cela et le point mais
remonter par mon conseiller spécial par
un mail ça s'est établi je l'ai dans
lequel il a il me fait une note que vous
avez si vous n'avez pas vous la passer
dans laquelle il me fait une note en
disant voilà ce sur quoi nous sommes
d'accord et signaler le dossier de SOS
raciste qui manifestement ne trouve pas
de consensus il me demande à moi du coup
de trancher de rendre un arbitrage de
donner un avis favorable ou défavorable
au projet
je pense qu'il sur la question Laïs
complémentaire ils sont en liste
complémentaire avant la réunion du
comité de sélection
à la sortie du comité de sélection ils
sont sélectionnés je ne sais pas non
mais je le dis madame
vous faites partie du comité de
sélection je vous le rappelle vous êtes
fait représenter pour des raisons qui
vous sont propres
comité de sélection juridiquement en
tant que ministre vous faites partie du
comité de sélection comme vous le disiez
monsieur le droit est important la
réalité aussi est réellement je ne suis
pas dans le comité de sélection je n'ai
pas dit que vous aviez siéger je dis
simplement que juridiquement voilà vous
avez vous aviez pris des disposition
pour être membre du comité de sélection
alors en tout cas on me demande un
arbitrage on demande un avis pour
trancher un sujet qui manifestement
d'après ce que j'en comprends en tout
cas ne fait pas consensus je donne cet
avis et il me semble que le ministre est
fondé a donné un avis favorable ou
défavorable quand son administration ou
son cabinet le lui demande je ne rends
pas mon avis tout de suite
ce dont je dispose je demande une note
sur le projet ce qui démontre bien je ne
rends pas un avis sur une personne et
j'y reviendrai je demande une note sur
le projet pour qu'on puisse voir de quoi
il s'agit dans les notes que j'ai à ma
disposition et vous également
aujourd'hui le projet proposé par
l'association SOS racis qui est par
ailleurs une association tout à fait
respectable et partenaire de l'État et
de différents ministères et encore
aujourd'hui et récemment il est proposé
une action en deux temps l'une sur les
réseaux sociaux et donc qui correspond à
l'objet du fond Marianne et l'autre et
c'est pourquoi je répondais tout à
l'heure à la question de Monsieur
sénateur concerne me semble-t-il des
activités sportives ou physiques dans
certains quartiers or cette proposition
d'action qui vise des qrr c'est à dire
40 quartiers de reconquête républicaine
et donc pas le champ national
contrairement à ce qui est demandé dans
l'appel à projet c'est une action qui
est déjà menée et déjà financée par des
fonds du FIPD par une autre organ qui
s'appelle raid aventure et qui fait
exactement ce travail de cohésion de
prévention dans les quartiers
qrr par le biais d'activités sportives
et donc j'imagine que c'est cela qui
amène à ce moment-là a considérer que
l'activité étant or réseau sociaux pour
par importante et de sous froide déjà
couvertes par une autre association
j'aimais manifestement j'en ai pas
souvenir mais manifestement j'ai mis un
avis défavorable en disant que pour moi
ce n'est pas un projet à retenir c'est
un avis que j'aimais et ensuite le
comité de sélection fait une liste
d'après les éléments dont je dispose
dans laquelle de figure pas SOS Racisme
je veux répondre à un élément qui est
fondamental sur ce sujet sur ce qu'a dit
Monsieur le Préfet j'allais qui est un
homme en qui j'ai toute confiance qui a
été mon directeur de cabinet à qui je
referai conscience à l'avenir si j'étais
amené à devoir le faire et qui est un
grand préfet mais mon ancien directeur
de cabinet
feta de relations personnelles de
désaccord personnel que j'aurais avec
monsieur le Président des SOS Racisme je
n'ai pas là non plus on me prête
beaucoup de relations personnelles mais
je n'ai pas de relation personnelle ni
de désaccord personnel ancien ou récent
avec monsieur le Président de SOS
racistes nous avons des désaccords sur
des points madame la ministre je vous
arrête parce que le temps court et qu'il
faut avancer et reconnaissez que il y a
quelque chose qui va pas vous nous
racontez votre vision des choses
on vous entend
très bien mais nous celles que l'ONA
n'est pas la même donc
quand vous dites d'abord comme vous
dites
le préfet j'allais etc j'ai parfaitement
confiance à lui mais il a dit des choses
qui sont fausses globalement c'est ce
que vous dites je ne dis pas que ce sont
des choses
je pense que c'est une interprétation de
sa part ou incompréhension peut-être de
ma faute peut-être de choses que j'ai
exprimé auprès de nos directeur de
cabinet qui l'amène à penser que j'ai un
antérieur personnel avec le président de
SOS racistes ce n'est pas le cas en tout
cas
la question est quand même beaucoup plus
excusez-moi de vous le dire beaucoup
plus simple il y a un comité de
sélection à l'entrée du comité de
sélection il y a des dossiers qui posent
pas de problème on va dire
il y a une liste supplémentaire à la
sortie du comité de sélection il y a
plus de liste supplémentaires c'est
terminé il y a un choix qui a été fait
par le comité de sélection et à ce
moment-là ils sont un peu l'imaginer
préférée dit
attention je fais une réserve sur un des
dossiers de comité de sélection retenu
dans un des dossiers retenus je fais une
réserve parce que je souhaite le
soumettre à la ministre bon alors deux
éléments derrière le premier c'est que
effectivement la remarque qui est faite
c'est une remarque de nature personnelle
et pas une remarque de nature
professionnelle donc ça vous dites le
préfet j'allais à une mauvaise
compréhension du sujet vous n'avez pas
au-delà de ça bon enfin il y a un sujet
peut-être de ma faute j'ai pu être
maladroite dans mon expression c'est
tout à fait possible
enfin tout de même je vais je vais être
très précis madame la ministre je vous
ai effectivement expliqué les montants
donc
on a le 20 mai
il y a une note de la chargée de mission
qui est envoyé au cabinet donc vous
n'êtes pas très éloigné qui indique que
le projet pourrait SOS Racisme est
d'accorder 100000 euros je rappelle
puisqu'il y avait questionnements que la
demande initiale était de 140.000 euros
et le premier juin il y a un membre de
votre cabinet qui a adressé un mail
indiquant que lors d'une réunion tenue
le même jour donc le 1er juin il a été
décidé de retirer à SOS Racisme
c'est 100000 euros et de verser 100 - 80
on sait pas pourquoi 20 000 euros au
profit d'une autre association l'effet
la matérialité des faits c'est ça et
uniquement ça
voilà et puis surtout sur l'idée de
voyez bien que sa mère en difficulté
votre position sur finalement
j'ai laissé travailler le comité de
sélection alors c'est vrai dans une
certaine mesure à part qu'il y a eu des
choses qui ont été faites en amont on
l'a dit des choses qui sont faites
pendant le comité de sélection sur
certaines associations qui sont jugées
trop
trop faible enfin en tout cas ne
répondons pas à l'exigence
gouvernementale je vous dis que ce
point-là était
pouvant être entendu et puis ensuite à
la fin à l'après le comité de sélection
alors que la liste était établie et bien
on vient retirer à une association un
montant et ça vient si vous voulez
contredire d'une certaine façon alors
l'idée de dire moi mon rôle c'était de
dire voilà comité de sélection
sélectionne ce qu'on pouvait entendre
parce que votre vous étiez représenté
par votre cabinet déjà dans le comité de
sélection donc
majorité de sélection sélectionne et moi
je valide et bien non
vous n'avez pas validé la vie du comité
de sélection vous avez dit sur une
association ça me convient pas alors
est-ce que le préfet Jallet s'est trompé
dans son interprétation
ou est-ce qu'il faut retenir votre
interprétation voilà d'une certaine
façon
n'étant pas là c'est pas nous qui
pouvons mais on note une autre quelque
chose de différent voilà monsieur le
Président je pourrais être très clair je
ne dis pas que je n'ai pas donné d'avis
sur SOS Racisme j'ai manifestement donné
un avis négatif sur le projet des SOS
Racisme avis qu'on m'a demandé là où je
dis qu'il y a une différence
d'interprétation
avait déjà eu lieu et que vous
avez été opéré et que vous rangiez à la
vie du comité de sélection vous n'aviez
pas donné un avis sur les les finalement
les associations déjà sélectionnées
monsieur le président
de demande mon avis on vient non mais je
ne m'immise pas dans le comité de
sélection on vient requérir un arbitrage
ministériel sur un sujet en particulier
et sur un seul donc je ne prends pas
part je le répète je ne prends pas part
au comité de sélection à aucun moment je
n'y siège pas et je ne donne pas de
consigne la meilleure preuve en est
c'est qu'on me remonte pour elle si
j'avais donné des consignes chacun
aurait mes consignes en tête là on me
remonte pour arbitrage ou pour avis
favorable ou défavorable je vous donne
un avis et c'est à l'issue de cet avis
que la décision est prise et ça se passe
toujours ainsi après la réunion du
comité de sélection il y a une liste et
dans cette liste ne figure pas
l'association des SOS Racisme après
étude du projet
on a
essayé de donner la matérialité des
faits le déroulement
vous vous tenez à l'écart mais vous
gardez un regard et même une capacité de
décider les choses sont finalement plus
claires comme ça c'est une manière de
reconnaître que vous avez un pouvoir de
décision tout en vous tenant à l'écart
vous êtes présente pour décider voilà
vous avez
vous avouer
avoir un rôle et une capacité à décider
et à trancher mais c'est mieux de le
dire que de tournicoter autour d'une
décision en expliquant que vous y êtes
mais pas tout à fait vous êtes à côté
c'est logique c'est de ça relève de
votre responsabilité le comité de
sélection comprend pour la moitié des
membres de votre cabinet c'est
parfaitement logique on pourrait vous
reprocher l'inverse bien sûr ce sont
monsieur le rapporteur deux choses
différentes ce n'est pas que je tourne
autour c'est que je tiens à être précise
et si ce n'est pas
je ne sais pas par disposition à
vous-même je permettrai pas de
vous êtes précis monsieur le rapporteur
vos questions sont précises bien
évidemment je tâche de l'être aussi sur
la base des faits dont j'ai souvenir ou
que j'ai matériellement je ne suis pas
dans le comité de sélection et quand on
demande un avis au ministre le ministre
donne un avis là encore s'il lui fallut
procéder autrement et que dans les dans
les retours d'expérience et dans les
recommandations ou préconisations que
vous ferez vous considérer que le
ministre ne doit pas rendre un avis ou
un arbitrage quand il lui est demandé
sur des subventions c'est tout à fait
entendable et pourquoi pas mais à ce
stade on vient je ne vais pas
d'initiative au comité de sélection me
remonter mon me demande un avis je
demande qu'on regarde le projet et je
donne un avis et ensuite le comité
établit une liste finale et je rappelle
que seul le cpdr est fondé à mettre les
crédits en paiement ou à attribuer une
finie les subventions ce qu'il faut
[Musique]